ونحييكم مشاهدينا مستمرين مستمرون معكم في
تغطتنا للتطورات في السودان الحديث عن
الوساطات يتزايد سفير جزر القمر في فرنسا
وعضو مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه
اكد في لقاء مع العربيه ان طرفي نزاع وافق
على مبادره افريقيه للتسويه وان هذه
المبادرات تتضمن وقفا دائما للنار وان
رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي يعتزم زياره
الخرطوم شرطه توفر الضمانات الامنيه
وضمن حديث الوسطات اكد وزير خارجيه جنوب
السودان ان رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان اكد لرئيس جنوب
السودان سيلفاكير موافقته على لقاء قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان ديجلو خارج
الخرطوم واوضح وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان
ان محاوله اقناع ماتي للقاء البرهان ما
زالت مستمره
ومع استمرار المواجهات في السودان والجهود
الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق النار اعلن
البيت الابيض عن العمل مع طرف يسرع في
السودان لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار لوقف
العنف وتامين المسارات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان وقفه اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر
رغم بعض الخروقات بالاضافه الى عمليه
القصف العشوائي التي اسفرت عن مقتل مدنيين
بينهم امريكيون هو ثاني حتى الان واكد
البيت الابيض على مواصله العمل لتامين
خروج كل مواطن امريكي يريد مغادره الاراضي
السودانيه
من جهته قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
لويس ميغلب وينو قال ان الاتحاد يرحب
بالهدن الانسانيه في السودان لكنه يريد
الوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار دائم
كنا نرحب بطبيعه الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه
من سنيه في السودان بعد ايام من من الصراع
ولكن صحيح هناك اعلانات هنا هناك
لاختراقات وانتحاكات لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر
دعواتنا لنتراخ المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت نار دائم
نرصد التطورات من منطقه المعموره جنوب
الخرطوم مراسلات العربيه ريان ظاهر ريان
اهلا بك معنا اليوم في ساعات سابقه من هذه
التغطيه كنا رصدنا معك الاجواء داخل
المحلات التجاريه مع حذر تحدثت عنه
لمواطنين سودانيين من امكانيه ان تنفذ بعض
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه خاصه حدثين عن
جوانب اخرى من هذا الموضوع وكيف تدو صوره
عموما جنوب الخرطوم
يعني لم اسمع السؤال
الذي تدين سؤالك نسبه يعني اصوات السيارات
لكن ما اود ان اقوله انها كانت حركه يعني
لا باس بها بالقرب من المحل التجاريه
لم تكن مقتظه هذه المحاله التجاريه رغم
اغلاق عدد كبير من المحالات التجاريه يعني
كنا نتوقع ان وجدنا محل او اثنين نجد
اتضاض او صفوف من المشترين لكن لم نجد
وكانت بعض الارفف يعني
تنفذ منها المواد التموينيه والغذائيه
وللاسف حتى المياه المعدنيه بدات بالنفاذ
الاصحاب هذه المحاله التجاريه يقولون انهم
يستوردون من مخازنهم وليس من مخازن
المصانع الكبرى لا يستطيعون
[موسيقى]
الترحيل الوقود كل هذه المشكلات تشكل هذه
الازمه التي يعاني منها المواطن السوداني
الذي مهدد في مقبل الايام ربما
بشح اكبر في المواد الغذائيه وربما نفاذها
هذا اكثر ما يغلق المواطن السوداني وهذا
هو الخطر القادم تلك كانت اصوات مناشدات
من المشترين والمواطنه السوداني والحركه
الشرائيه وايضا من اصحاب المحال ايضا
حاولنا رصد الباعه المتجولين وسماع
اصواتهم والان يعني
لا توجد حركه بهذا الشارع يعني ذهب الجميع
واغلقوا ابوابهم وهذا الشارع يبدو خاليا
تماما من الماره واغلقت هذه المحاله
التجاريه ابوابها ربما
وضحت هذه الفكره طالما بدانا في رصد نفاذ
المواد الغذائيه نحن نتحدث عن منطقه شبه
امنه يعني لم نعد نتحدث عن اشتباكات لم
نعد نتحدث عن حذر فيما يخص عمليه عسكريه
وبالتالي يمكن القول بان جنوب الخرطوم امن
صحيح
فعلا يعني لم نشهد هنا اشتباكات رغم بعض
الاصوات العاليه والمدويه لكن لم نشهد هنا
اشتباكات لذلك الباعه يبررون بان هذه
المنطقه امنه وبالتالي يستطيعون ان
يمارسوا مهنتهم وتجارتهم كما يعني كما كما
الحال لكن بذات المنطقه بالامس لو تذكرين
حاولنا ارد عدد من سكان ولايه الخرطوم
وايضا بعض الجاليات الاخرى التي تحاول
الخروج خارج ولايه الخرطوم وربما خارج
السودان في ذات المنطقه التي تشهد نوعا ما
امان يعني والموضوع لا يخلو من بعض
الارتكازات نعم وضعت الفكره نعود لك في
نشاطنا القادمه من منطقه المعموره جنوب
الخرطوم مراسله العربيه رايا الظاهر شكرا
جزيلا لك
نتابع مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا
بك معنا دكتور امين دكتور امين هذه
المرحله بعد ايام كنا
عشناها وتبعنا من خلالها التطورات فداخل
السوداني مع الشبكات المتقطعه الان هناك
هدوء حظر الان للشبكات مختصره فقط في داخل
الخرطوم كما طردنا الاخبار على الاقل وهي
متقطعه هذه المرحله عسكريا هل هي تهيئه
لامكانيه فتح ابواب لتفاوض حقيقي حضرتك
خبير كيف تقرا هذه المرحله
مساء الخير مرحب بك ومرحب بيك الساده
المشاهدين هذه المرحله الثالثه من عمليات
المدن مرحله التطهير والمطارده تقوم بها
القوات المسلحه لمجموعات الدعم السريع
التي انحازت الى المناطق السكنيه في
محاوله للاحتمال بها منعا للقصص ومنعا
للاستخدام القوه من القوات المسلحه
نعم فاذا اذا تم تطوير هذه الهدنه الى
وقفه الارنار بيكون
العمليات ان شاء الله في نهاياتها واتوقع
انه في الان وساطه قويه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد الافريقي
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ربما تقود الى
الى لقاء بين الاطراف المتصارعه ولو على
مستوى الخبراء
بجانب انه الهدنه غدا ستنتهي بمنتصف الليل
اللي هو فجر يوم
تتجدد بحسب ما فهمت من حضرتك ولكن لواء
امين تحدثت عن الوسطات وهي متعدده كن ذكر
جزء منها هذه الوصفات اتت في الفتره
الاخيره وحتى في الايام الاولى كانت هناك
مناشدات وكانت هناك مبادرات وتصريحات في
هذا الخصوص ولكن حضرتك هذه الوصفات واخرها
ما تحدث
بخصوصه سفير جزر القمر بان هناك وساطه من
الاتحاد الافريقي ويمكن
هذا النزاع ان ينتهي بوقف دائم لاطلاق
النار شرطه توفر الضمانات الامنيه مضمنه
الامنيه التي يجب ان تتوفر للبدء بتنفيذ
اي وساطه كانت
طرح فكره جلوس الاطراف على طويله نقاش
واحده
الامنيه هي في محورين المحور الاول ضمانات
امنيه لدخول رؤساء من بعض الدول تعهدوا
بالوصول الى الخرطوم اللقاء مع الطرفين
يحتاجون الى تامينات المطار تامين
المغارات دي من الناحيه الداخليه من
المحور الاخر هو ضمانات امنيه للخروج
القاده من الطرفين
للغاء سواء كان داخل الخرطوم او اللقاء
خارج السودان هذه الضمانات الامنيه ايضا
هنالك ضمانات مطلوبه ايضا للفصل بين
المجموعتين
الخبراء والمرافقين الذين سياتون للفصل
بين المجموعتين يجب ان يكون هنالك تصميم
واراده من الطرفين بعدم تعرضهم لاي نوع من
انواع الاعتداء راينا بعض الوفيات حدثت
لعنصر من السفاره المصريه ويمكن فيه برضو
عنصر من الضمان الامريكيه هذه هي الضمانات
المطلوبه داخليا وخارجيا لاكمال وصول
الرؤساء
واجمال المواطنه فقط ونحن نتحدث اسمحلي
اولا ان تبقى معنا حتى نشير الى بعض الصور
في الواقع على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هي
صور تظهر تحرك لقوات كبيره من الجيش الى
الخرطوم وكانت في هذا الاطار افادت مصادر
ان تلك الق من ولايات الجزيره ونيل الابيض
ونهر النيل متابع هذه الصور واعود لك فيما
بعد سياده اللواء نناقشها ونفهمها اكثر
معك
[موسيقى]
والله
الدكتور امين اسماعيل لواء مين وانت تتحدث
معنا فقط لنتاكد الصوره امامك صوره
العربيه يعني تابعت هذا الفيديو ام لا
طالما الصوره مش امامك خليني اصف لك هذه
صور تداولتها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فيها عربات بالعشرات في الواقع تتوجه الى
داخل الخرطوم نحن سنبقى مع هذه الصور
لنتاكد من دقتها اولا ومن توقيت يعني متى
حدثت هي نشرت في الساعات الاخيره وحتى في
الدقائق الاخيره قبل هذا الساعه ولكن ان
صدقت هذه المعلومات وهناك توجه لكل هذه
العربات العسكريه الى داخل الخرطوم ما
الذي يعني ذلك
ونحن سنبقى في متابعه كل هذه التفاصيل
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر من الخرطوم اللواء
الدكتور امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز الدراسات الدوليه شكرا
لك
في خبر اخر كان اعلن الجيش السوداني تصدي
لهجوم لقوات الدعم السريع على مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم وقال
الجيش انه كبد قوه الدعم السريع خسائر
فادحه بحسب البيان واتهم الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع بمواصله خرق الهدنه المعلنه
[تصفيق]
لكل الهجوم
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودين المواطنين ماشيين
ماشيين
المواطنين العاديين دايرين يمشوا ياخذوا
لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه لانه ما في قوه
يعني تحميم اي زول امشي يحمي نفسه
حملت قوه الدعم السريع المجتمع الدولي
مسؤوليته تجاه خلق الهدنه من قبل قياده
الجيش السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم التزام
قيادات الجيش بالهدنى تؤكد تعدد مراكز
القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوه دعم
السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه مواقعها
بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض المعسكرات
وسوبا في وقت واحد
من جهته دعا وزير الماليه السوداني وزعيم
حركه العدل والمساواه جبر الابراهيم دعا
الشباب الى تشكيل لجن شعبيه لحمايه المدن
المتاثره بالحرب وقال جبريل ابراهيم في
تغريده على حسابه على تويتر ان الوضع في
مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
يتسم بالفوضى العارمه مشددا على ضروره
التحرك لايقاف الماساه هناك على حد تعبيره
اناناس مواطنين مسالمين دارين ياكلوا لقمه
الايش
المشكله بقى خطيره علينا
[موسيقى]
الناس
المساجين ودرايل الصناعيه للنظم بيشتغلوا
اليوم باليوم وانت يا النفرين انا الدائري
منكم بس تهزوا
الدعم السريع المستمره في اطلاق النار
بمطار الخرطوم وبحري واندرمان وفق اعلان
الجيش السوداني ومن الخرطوم الى ولايه غرب
دارفور مشاهدينا فقد تجددت الاشتباكات في
مدينه الجنينه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
وسط الاحياء السكنيه
تعبنا نحن ما حنطلع من بيوتا من بيوتنا ما
حنطلع انا حنموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد
احنا اولادنا يقوموا من الصبح عشان يجيبوا
لنا مويه لغايه بالليل
موت عشان نشرب نحن وين حد وين يا حد وين
يا حماتي يا اخي خافوا الله فينا خافوا
الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
[موسيقى]
وقف القتال في البلاد مشددا على ان القتال
لن يكون حلا للصراع بين القوتين غوتيرش
دعا قاده السودان لجعل مصالح شعبهم اولويه
وان يقوموا باسكت اسلحتهم فورا
وكانت بريطانيا عبرت عن قلقها ازاء
التقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفق مره
اخرى بالوفاء في التزاماتهما حول الهدنه
ودعت بريطانيا قوه الجيش والدعم السريع
الى وقف دائما لاطلاق النار وانهاء العنف
بالاضافه الى السماح بوصول للمساعدات
الانسانيه وضمان حمايه المدنيين والعاملين
في المجال الانساني وطبي
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
قلم رسل العربيه ان نحو سبع طائرات عسكريه
تصل يوميا الى برج سودان للاجلائي
بالتنسيق مع الجيش هذا ووصلت احدى طائرات
الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده السعوديه محمله
32 شخصا كما تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى ليبيا
عبر ثلاث مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا
بالانتقال بالحافلات الى بورتسودان ثم الى
ميناء جده وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره في
طرابلس واستقبل مطار معتيكا الدولي 105 من
افراد الجاليه الليبيه في السودان بعد
اجلائهم واكدت الجزائر ان ثلاثه عشر
فلسطينيا و22 سوريا وعددا اخر من الراعي
بالخرطوم قدموا من مطار بورت سودانا
وفي مسلسل المعاناه السودانيين المدنيين
يشكون مشاهدينا من رصاص الدوشكا الروسي
ويقولون انه يخترق جدران المنازل وانه
يصيبهم باصاباتنا بالغه
من القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدى الرمي الى ثلاثه الاف وخمائه متر
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
عشره
مشاهدينا على نطاق واسع سارع الدول عربيه
وحكومات اجنبيه باجلاء رعاياها من السودان
الامر الذي اعده البعض مؤشرا على طول امد
الحرب عمليه الاجلاء المتسارعه تتم عبر
البحر والجو والبر كذلك السعوديه كانت اول
الدول التي نظمت عمليه الاجلاء بحرا من
ميناء بورتسودان عند هذه النقطه من
الخريطه على البحر الاحمر الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده حيث هذه النقطه
بمشاركه سفن جلاله الملك ينبع وجلاله
الملك الجبيل وسفينه امامنا كذلك تمكنت من
نقل الاف من السعوديين والعرب والاجانب من
دبلوماسيين كذلك جوا تعددت نقاط الاجلاء
طائرات حربيه من قاعده امريكيه في جيبوتي
انطلقت الى السودان لاجلاء جميع الموظفين
الامريكيين وعائلتهم كذلك مطار بورسودان
الدولي كان كذلك نقطه اخرى لعمليه الاجلاء
هنا المطار دول اخرى انشات جسرا جويا
عسكريا حيث نقلت بريطانيا رعاياها مثلا
عبر طائره تابعه لسلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني الى مطار لارناكا في قبرص وعن
طريق البر خرج رعايه تركيا من الخرطوم برا
الى العاصمه هنا من الخرطوم خرجوا الى
العاصمه الاثيوبيه حيث اجلت انقره رعاياها
من هناك في حين شهد معبر قسطل وارقين في
مصر وصوله عشرات الالاف هنا المعبران هنا
لدينا قسطل وارقين وشهد عبور عشرات الالاف
من الاشخاص وسط انتشارا للقوات الامنيه
المصريه لتامين عمليه الاجلاء والنزوح
الاستغلال استغلال ذاته بشر
يعني التذكره الصباح
بسعد والنسب بسعر الفاصل خمس مقاعد لكن
يعني
مليار وخمسين مليار وخمسين
متابعه هذا التطورات مع ضيفنا منهم
دورتمانه صحفي مقداد حسن سيد مقداد اهلا
بك معنا اسمحلي كمصافحه اولى ان ابدا
بالتفاصيل من عندك ان كان هناك اي جديد
يخص اندرمان كنا في نشرات سابقه تحدثنا عن
مواد الغذائيه تحدثنا عن نقص الوقود
والطوابير تحدثنا كذلك عن المستشفيات
واستهداف مستشفى
هذه الملفات او جديد اخر مثلا من عندك
اهلا اهلا
نعم مدينه درمان
بطبيعه الحال كغيرها من المدن في الجهات
الشماليه والغربيه للهاتف نسبي في حياه
الناس الطبيعيه هدوء يعتبر حريق بعض الشيء
هنالك تواجد او تواجد ميداني لقوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم التاريخي في بعض الشوارع
وهنالك اشتباكات بحسب من تواصلنا معهم في
الجهه الجنوبيه لمدينه
تحديدا المنطقه الصالحه هنالك اكثر من
ثلاثه قزائد شوهدت في عدد من المواطنين مع
وقعت مداوره لمنازلهم لم يحدث منها اي
اصابات لكن تعتبر هذه القذائف قابله
للانتجار لان واحده منها لم
تطور مقداد في اي وقت لانه كنا في نشرات
سابقه نتحدث عن هدوء حظر هذه القذائف
انطلقت يعني هل يمكن الحديث على مكان
انطلقت منه
يمكن الحديث عن الحدود الجغرافيه للمكان
الذي انطلقت منه هي المنطقه التي تقع جنوب
مدينه درمان تحديدا المنطقه الصالحه بحسب
من تواصلنا معهم
ويمكن ان
تتحدثوا معهم قبل اكثر من ثلاث ساعات على
وجه الدقه
لم لم توجد هنالك اي اصابات وشاهدوا كذلك
بعض الاشتراكات لبعض الاشتباكات في تلك
المنطقه وهنالك ايضا في فتره الصباحيه او
في في صباح هذا اليوم كانت هنالك اشتراكات
متعدده في تلك المنطقه تحديدا في ذكرى
سيدي اما في المنطقه الغربيه
المكان مقداد ريف اندرمان كبير
يعني يمتد
قصدي يمتد على مساحات شاسعه المكان اللي
يشهد هذه الاشتباكات
المكان الذي يشهد هذه الاشتباكات في
المنطقه التي فيها بها المواقع
الاستراتيجيه
للجيش السوداني منطقه سلاح المهندسين
والسلاح الطبي وكذلك المحيط الاذاعه
العامه هذه المناطق تحديدا تتجدد فيها
الاشتباكات بين الفينه والاخرى بين قوات
الدعم السريعه والجيش السوداني هنالك
انحسار توهب احد المواطنين في منطقه
البلده انتشار على طول الطريق الذي يربط
جنوبهم درمان بشمالها تحديدا المنصوره
والمهندسين والجزء
الشمالي من هذا الطريق طريق الصناعات
هنالك تواجد لقوات الدعم السريع في هذا في
هذه المنطقه
السباكات
تتجدد بين الفين والاخرى
جميعها سهلت في الفتره الصباحيه وفتره
الظهيره في منطقه الصالحه تحديدا اما
بالنسبه لل
المستشفيات تقريبا منطقه ام دربان تعمل
بها ثلاث مستشفيات
وتحتاج الى احتياجات صحيه كبيره
كان هنالك نداء من داخل المستشفى مستشفى
النووي في منطقه توجد ايضا حوده عادله
الطبيه ولتلافل الدوائي اما هنالك
مستشفيات اخرى هي الان تعمل بحسب اللجنه
التنفيذيه قبل الاطباء السودان كمستشفى
البقعه ومستشفى اسيا مستشفى اسيا على وجه
التحديد من المستشفيات التي تقع في منطقه
القديمه حي الشهداء وهو من الاحياء التي
تحيط بها الاشتباكات لانه يقع قريبا من
ابن النساء وهيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
وكذلك مستشفى الحكيمه مستشفى الوداد
ومستشفى
وهي كلها تعتبر مستشفيات مرسيديه في منطقه
وضحت الفكره شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان مقداد
حسن الصحفي كنت معنا من اندرمان
عمليات نزوح التي يحاول السودانيون القيام
بها لا تخلو من التحديات والمخاطر
التفاصيل والمزيد في هذا التقرير
تشتد الازمه هناك وتنفرج في المعابر
والموانئ والمطارات لكن قبل الوصول الى بر
الامان ثم تحديات يجب تخطيها
ولعل الوضع الامني المتردي اخطر تحدي لذا
تشكل الهدن متنفسا للحركه لكن ذلك مرهون
بالتزام طرفي النزاع بوقف اطلاق النار
فمنذ اكثر من عشره ايام اعلن عن اربع هدن
بواسطات دوليه العنوان الابرز لها خروق
وانهيار العائق الثاني في حال تجاوز
الفرينه هشاشه الهدن يتمثل في كلفه التنقل
فثمن تذكره الرحله الى بورتسودان من
الخرطوم في الحافله يصل الى 400 دولار
للشخص الواحد لكن ثمه ازمه اخرى محطات
وقود مغلقه اما الانقطاع الوقود او
الاستهدافها تشهد الاسعار ارتفاعات كبيره
فتكلفه الجالون في السوق السوداء بلغت 50
دولارا اي عشره اضعاف السعر الرسمي
وللتنقل لابد من الدفع هنا مشكله اخرى لا
ولا صرافات اليه والبنوك مغلقه حتى تحويل
الاموال عبر تطبيقات الهواتف لا يعمل
معضله اخرى قذائف وشظايا لم تنفجر قد تكون
في انتظار اصطياد ضحيتها لذا تشدد المنظمه
على تجنب التعامل مع اي منها
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الخيارات المره والصعبه يختار
البعض المخاطره غير ان اخرين يفضلون
البقاء في منازل ستكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر
امنا من مخاطر رحله قد لا تكون محسوبه
العواقب
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من واشنطن عبر
مرقس واستاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس منظمه
دكتور بول اهلا بك معنا الى هذه التغطيه
للازمه السودانيه كنت تبع معنا هذا
التقرير وفي الواقع هذا التقرير يعرض بدقه
بعض
الصعوبات التي تعترض السودانيين بداخل
ازمه غلاء كبيره يعني هناك تذاكر من 20
دولار وصلت الى 400 دولار انقطاع المياه
هناك
احتكار للسلع الغذائيه والصراع الاساسيه
كل هذا الى اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر في عمل
الجهات الحقوقيه بمعنى انها قد يستفزها
وما الذي يمكن فعله لمحاوله المساعده على
القل في هذه الاوقات الحرجه
بالفعل هنا في نيويورك في مكان قريب هنالك
يعني سعي لتكثيف عمليات المساعده
الانسانيه لكن هنالك عوائق على الميدان في
الميدان تقف عائقا امام هذه المساعدات رغم
الشحف المساعدات والقصور ايضا في ذلك يعني
عمليات نهب وسرقه هنالك عرقله بالنسبه
للاوراق الثبوتيه التي لا يحوزها بالضروره
من يريد ان يلجا الى بلاد اخرى وهنالك
تعرفين التدفق الهائل لنحو 300 الف لاجئ
على مختلف الحدود باتجاه تشاد باتجاه مصر
باتجاه جنوب السودان وسواها اذا هنالك
ايضا مساله التاشيرات هنالك ارتفاع في
تذاكر السفر الى هنالك من المشقات التي لا
يمكن بالضروره التصدي لها اماميا او
بالنسبه للمساعدات
هنالك داخل ايضا ازمه خطيره تتعلق بالمواد
الطبيه وخروج المستشفيات عن الخدمه اذا
يعني المساله في الداخل وعلى الحدود
متازمه الى حدود يجب البحث جديا في انهاء
هذا النزاع لا بد من ذلك مع احترام
المواثيق الدوليه يعني هنالك خرق هائل
الاتفاقيات جنيف الاربعه
وبروتوكولاتها هنالك خرق ايضا الاتفاقيه
حقوق اللاجئين لعام 1951 من قبل الدول
ايضا المحيطه وبالتالي هنالك ازمه
كبرى ومتعدده الجوانب يجب التصدي لها على
نحو افضل
ولكن يبقى سؤال كيف بمعنى كيف اولا ومن
يتحمل مسؤوليه بمعنى دكتور بول ما تابعناه
من صعوبات ان كان فيما يخص الوقود فيما
يخص الاساسيات فيما يخص ااا
اتذكر والغلاء كل هذا يمكن ان يكون موجود
كذلك وحضرتك تعلم في دول اخرى لا تشهد
حروب هناك دول تعيش بطريقه عاديه ولكن
هناك اختناق سياسي بالداخل مضطرها ومضطر
شعبها الى العيش بهذه الصعوبات ولكن لما
نكون امام حرب وطرفان معروفان الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تكون هناك ادانه كذلك لهذه
الاطراف
بربطها مع ما يعيشها الشعب في هذه الاثناء
من تدهور
بطبيعه الحال هنالك مسؤوليه بالنسبه
للداخل السوداني وهذا امر لا يمكن انكاره
لكن طالما ان النزاع تفلت والمسؤوليه تشتت
وهنالك حرب فعليه قائمه ومن الصعب ردعها
ووقفها حاليا يجب النظر واعاده النظر في
الاساليب والطرق
يعني المخارج الدوليه
تمت في السنين العشر الاخيره نزاعات حربيه
كثيره وقعت منها في سوريا مرورا باوكرانيا
اخيرا ادت الى دفق هائل من اللاجئين لم
تعرف الامم المتحده باجهزتها ووكالاتها
المتخصصه كيفيه التصدي على نحو فاعل وجذري
للامر يجب اذا تاهيل
الوكالات المتخصصه في حال وقوع حروب لا
يمكن القول اننا لن نشفت حروب للاسف
الشديد لكن يجب
تفعيل اليات الازمه والتصدي على نحو متعدد
وعميق ومباشر
لاخراج المدنيين
وتحييد المنشات المدنيه من مدار هكذا
نزاعات حربيه ولكن باختصار دكتور من الذي
يجب ان يطرح مثل هكذا خطه للازمه تتحدث عن
امم المتحده وان كان نعم كيف لها ان تفرض
مثل هكذا خطه وهي في المقابل غير قادره
على الحركه في الدخل السوداني
هذا امر صحيح لذلك شاركنا في الكثير من
المؤتمرات بعضها في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هنا وسواها من الدول التي طرحت
بالفعل اعاده النظر في اليات التصدي
الدوليه عندما يقع نزاع داخلي يؤدي الى
حرب وبالتالي لا يمكن تلافي نزاعات
الداخليه ولا حتى الحروب للاسف نقول لكن
يجب اعاده النظر في الاليات الدوليه عن
طريق اعاده النظر في تركيبه مجلس امن
الدولي في كيفيه التصوير داخل هذا المجلس
في كيفيه عمل المنظمات الدوليه واليه
المنح والهبات والمساعدات والممرات
الميدانيه
والجسور التي تبنى للتصدي هكذا ازمات ليس
لازمه بعينها انما بسبب وقوع ازمات
متتاليه تؤدي الى دفق هائل من اللاجئين
هذا الامر لم يحصل بذلك
اود شكرك جزيلا شكرا على كل ما تفضلت به
من واشنطن عبر سكايب الدكتور بول مرقس
استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس منظمه جوسيسيا
الحقوق يه شكرا لك
ساهمت سفينه امانه السعوديه باجلاء مئات
الاشخاص من مختلف جنسيات العالم مسجله
بذلك اكبر عمليه اجلاء من السودان حتى
الان نتعرف على هذه السفينه
سفينه امان السعوديه تقوم باكبر عمليه
اجلاء من السودان السفينه ترفع علم
السعوديه منذ 44 عاما
ايطاليه الصنع تملكها شركه نماء للتجاره
الدوليه عرضها يصل الى 23 مترا وطولها
لمئه وثمانيه واربعين مئات الرعايه
الاجانب استخدموها لتنقلهم من ميناء سواكن
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
يصلون لوجهتهم المستقره وتغمرهم فرحه
النجاه يلوحون لها شكرا امانه على الامانه
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع يا محمد معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان فيه يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما قال
لنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني صراحه كان كل شي منظم ما شاء
الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم قاعدين
يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان موضوع جدا سهل
ايوه اهلي من هنا تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم
قالوا لهم نروح على الميناء البري البحري
هذا هو كانت واكبات كاميرا العربيه وصول
البارجات والقطع البحريه لمختلف الدول فور
وصولها الى ميناء بورتسودان حيث وثقت
العربيه وصول قطعتين بحريه هنديه الى
الميناء من اجل نقل الجاليه الهنديه
واجنائها في احد المراسي هنا في مدينه
تحديدا في الميناء الاخضر بالميناء
الشمالي
باخره او قطعتان حربيتان بحريتان ووصلتا
صباح هذا اليوم الى ميناء بورسودان يتبعان
لدوله الصين
يستعدان لاجلاء النحو 600 من رعايه الصين
هنا في بورسودان وصلوا خلال اليومين
الماضيين اما هنا فهذه القطع البحريه
العسكريه الهنديه ايضا قبل قليل اكتملت
كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه بالدخول رعايه
دوله الهند في اطار مراحل مختلفه
تعلم بان عدد الجاليه الهنديه في السودان
يقدر بنحو 4000
معبر ورقين البريه الفاصل بين الحدود
المصريه والسودانيه امل الفارين من
الاشتباكات في السودان خصوصا من مدينه
الخرطوم واندرمان كثيرون تحدثوا عن خطوره
الاوضاع وصعوبه الرحله من السودان وصولا
للحدود المصريه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
معه المزيد من التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
نحن الان في منفذ عرجيل اخر نقطه الحدوديه
لعبور المصريين والسودانيين والرعايه
الاجانب الذين يهربون من جحيم ما يحدث في
السودان الى مصر
الضرب
الخرطوم والضرب بيقع عشوائي بيجي ضرب يعني
لحد ما وصلنا القاهره في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لظهور شديد
وضحايا شديد
والغنابل بتقع في خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروف عن القهوه
[موسيقى]
ومن خلال هذه الحافلات سينتقلون الى
وجهتهم المقبله مدينه اسوان التي تبعد عن
هذا المنفذ حدودي 500 كلم
[موسيقى]
وصلت اول طائرات تقل رعايه قادمين من
السودان الى مطار ستانستيد قرب العاصمه
لندن بعد ان اجلتهم الحكومه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا وصلت اول طائره اجلات تابعه للخطوط
الملكيه المغربيه الى مطار محمد الخامس
الدولي في مدينه الدار البيضاء
[موسيقى]
وفي تطورات اخرى من الاسماء السودانيه في
تطورات وتداعيات هروب عدد من رموز النظام
السابق من سجن كوبر بالعاصمه الخرطوم اكد
في هذا الصدد الجيش السوداني ان رئيس
السابق عمر البشير لا يزال محتجزا بمستشفى
عسكري تحت حراسه الشرطه القضائيه وقال
الجيش في بيان له ان البشير وعدد من قياده
حزبه محتجزون في مستشفى علياء العسكري
الجيش عبر عن رفضه لاي محاولات لربط ما
يجري في السجون بمزايدات على مواقفه
الوطنيه ووصف الجيش السوداني الدعم
السريعه واقد قائده بانهم امتداد للنظام
السابق
واما الشرطه السودانيه فقط حملت قوات
الدعم السريع مسؤوليه اطلاق سراح السجناء
بالاضافه الى الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المواطنين واكدت الشرطه ان الدعم السريعه
اطلق سراحا نزل في سته سجون بالخرطوم
والولايات الاخرى الشرطه قالت ايضا ان قوه
الدعم السريع اقتحمت سجنه كوبر وتسببت في
قتل وجرح عدد من قوات الشرطه
في المقابل اتهم المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت اتهمها قيادات
مواليه للبشير في الجيش بالمسؤوليه عن
اطلاق سراح قياده النظام السابق من سجن
كوبر واضاف في تصريحاته للعربيه بان
مغادره قياده النظام البشير للسجن كان
امرا متوقعا بحسب كلامه
للكلاب الحركه الاسلاميه الذي
نتوقع كل هذا العناصر الاسلاميه داخل
الجيش انا لا اتهم كل الجيش الجيش ليس كله
حركه اسلاميه هنالك ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك
جهات داخل الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك
جهاز ضباط اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراحه
هذه المجموعه ونحن لدينا معلومات من داخل
السجن لحظه اطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام السجن
لحظه اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا لم
تكن قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه
عزه قال ايضا للعربيه ان من مسؤوليه الدعم
السريع القاء القبض على من فرو من داخل
سجن كوبر
انا الان تنفيذ العمليه او كيفيه اخلاءه
من السجن اؤكد لك هذا هذا مجرد توقعات او
احتمالات او لاشخاص فيهم احمد هارون يوم
عبد الرحيم محمد
مسؤوليتنا وفي اطار حربنا والذي يواجهوننا
بها من مسؤوليتنا سنسعى بكل ما يمكن ان
يقبض القبض عليه
ومشاهدينا بالحديث عن سجنه كوبر الذي
غادرت منه قيادات من نظام البشير ابرزهم
احمد هارون فهذا السجن يقع في بحري
بالعاصمه الخرطوم يبعد عن المستشفى
العسكري نحو 10 كيلومترات اي حوالي سبعه
عشره دقيقه بالسياره وبحسب الجيش السوداني
يرقد الرئيس السابق في المستشفى العسكري
تحت رقبتنا امنيه قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات
اقدم سجنا في السودان افتتح عام
1903 يقع في حي كوبر بمدينه بحري قرب
النيل الازرق نسب اسمه الى الجنرال
البريطاني كوبر الذي تولى اداره السجن
مساحته 5000 متر مربع وتصميمه يحاكي سجون
بريطانيا يضم محكومين سياسيين وجنائيين
وشهد اشهر اعدامات الضباط [__] 14 قسما من
بينها قسم مخصص للمدانين باحكام الاعدام
وقسم لاصحاب السوابق واخر لذوي الاحكام
الطويله والقصيره وقسم للمعتقلين
السياسيين كان يضم الرئيس السابق البشير
وعددا من قيادات نظامه غادره عدد من
قيادات نظام البشير على خلفيه التدهور
الامني في البلاد
ما موقف اطراف الصراع في السودان من خروج
رموز نظام البشير من السجن
الجيش السوداني سلطه اداره السجون خارج
نطاق اختصاصنا وتحت مسؤوليه وزاره
الداخليه
الدعم السريع لا سيطره لدينا على السجون
في السودان وهذه مسؤوليه الشرطه
الميليشيات المتمرده اجبرت شرطه السجون
على اطلاق سراح النزلاء قيادات المواليه
للبشير في الجيش هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق
سراحه
اداره سجن كوبر اطلقت سراح نزلائه بسبب
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء والاعاشه خروج
قيادات البشير من سجن كوبر صدمه وانتكاسه
للشعب السوداني نحن غير معنيين باي بيانات
من اي جماعه او افراد خرجوا من السجون
مغادره قيادات النظام البشير للسجن امر
متوقع وبعضهم يطلبون دوليا
ومشاهدينا الى جده الان مع زميلنا عن
الصفيان مراسل العربيه هاني اهلا بك معنا
من جديد هل لازلت تتابع حركه المعتمرين ام
انك انتقلت اكثر فعلا انتقلت اكثر من خلال
هذه الصوره الى داخل الميناء في انتظار
وصول
يعني مواطنين رعايه اخرين حدثنا اكثر عن
الصوره هاني من عندك تفضل
[موسيقى]
الذين قدموا عبر هذه الناقله طبعا لو
نشاهد الصوره في الزاويه الاخرى ويلتقطها
المصور يقف اكثر من 60 شخص من
ممن قدموا وحملتهم هذه السفينه النفطيه
وهم جميعهم من الجنسيه الصينيه لحظه فقط
الاذن لنزولهم وبعد ذلك سوف تقلهم الحافله
المخصصه والتي وفرتها السعوديه وبعد ذلك
سوف ينتقلون مباشره الى مقر اقامتهم طبعا
اليوم نتحدث عن امر مختلف حقيقه الان واضح
جدا ان الامر داخل السودان وتحديدا في
بورتسودان واضح جدا انه صعب لماذا لانه
هذه السفينه ان نفطيه قامت باجلاء هؤلاء
المواطنين الصينيين ولعل الامر هنا كان
اشد صعوبه
فمشاهدتنا لهذه السفينه النفطيه وهي تحمل
رعايه ايضا من الصين وكذلك ايضا تنقلهم
الى مدينه جده فان وضعهم الصحي سوف يتضح
بعد قليل عند نزولهم نعم هناك مركبات
الاسعاف وهناك ايضا اداره الصحيه السعوديه
جاهزه ومتاهبه وايضا هناك قطاعات صحيه
موجوده من اجل التاكد من سلامتهم عند
نزولهم طبعا الجميع هنا في انتظار نزول
هؤلاء
المواطنين الصينيين هناك ايضا علامات
ترحيب وهناك ايضا من السفاره الصينيه التي
تقوم بوضع لافتات الترحيب من اجل هؤلاء
الصينيين وايضا نشاهد الحافلات الموجوده
هنا وايضا نشاهد في الجهه الاخرى ايضا
المركبات الصحيه ومركبات الاسعاف التي
وفرتها السعوديه بعد نزول هؤلاء الصينيون
من هذه السفينه لو نشاهد ضخامه هذه
السفينه والتي يبلغ طولها اكثر من
مترا نشاهد هي سفينه نفطيه كما تشاهدين
وهي سفينه نفطيه ولكنها ايضا
اضطرت الى حمل هؤلاء الصينيون عندما وقفت
الى
بورتسودان عندما قامت بتفريغ النفط هناك
واضطرت الى حمل هؤلاء بعد بحسب ما وصلنا
بعد المعاناه التي كانوا يعانونها من وجود
وجودهم هناك رغم انه هناك
الامر كان واضح ان كان بعضهم داخل الخرطوم
شاهد امرا مؤلما واوضاع ماساويه فاضطروا
جميعنا التوجه الى بورسودان وبعد ذلك
اقلتهم هذه السفينه التي وصلت قبل ساعه
وساعه الا ربع او قبل 45 دقيقه الى رصيف
ميناء جده الاسلامي طبعا نحن في انتظار
فقط نزولهم هناك طبعا في هذه الاثناء هناك
ايضا رحله اجلام متزامنه ولكنها في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه ويتم اجلاها من قبل
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه تصلونها
في هذه اللحظات معلومات ان القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه تقوم بعمليه اجلاء ووصول
لاكثر من
250 شخصا او قرابه الثلاثه شخصا من جنسيه
مختلفه يصلون الان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه وهي في الجهه الاخرى ومع هذا
الامر ومع هذا الخبر هناك تحرك ايضا
للمواطنين الصينيين عن على ظهر هذه
السفينه الذين يقومون الان بالتوجه الى
السلم المخصصي لهم
للنزول وبعد ذلك سوف نشاهدهم مشاهدات
الصور هاني وسنبقى مع هذه الصور فقط نذكر
باننا نتابع هذه الصور لوصول صينيين على
متن هذه الباخره النفطيه نحن في انتظار
نزولهم طبعا ولكن حدثني منذ قليل وقلت بان
وردتك بعض الاخبار مفادها وصول رعايه
اخرين في الجانب الاخر وبتحديد في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه حدثنا عن جغرافيه هذا
الميناء بمعنى انه نحن هذه الصور طردنا من
ميناء جده في مقابله بالتحديد نتحدث عن
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بمعنى انه
المسافه كم كيف يبدو تنظيم هذا الميناء
والقاعده كذلك
نتحدث عن وصول كم سفينه لانه بيتنا هاني
لا نتحدث فقط عن وصول هذه السفينه الصينيه
ولكن تحدثنا في ما قبل عن وصول سفينه
فرنسيه عن وصول كذلك رعايه بريطانيين فكيف
يتم تنظيم هذه العمليه الضخمه
صحيح في ظل الصور الان التي تلتقطها
للمشاهد الاوليه لنزول
الرعايه الصين الذين وصلوا للتو الان عبر
هذه السفينه النفطيه سوف اخبركم عن عمليه
التنظيميه التي تقوم بها السعوديه في
استقبال سواء للفرقاطات الحربيه او السفن
التجاريه من دول عده او كذلك لسفنها
الخاصه والعسكريه التابعه للقوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه
طبعا هذه الصور الاولى ولكن سوف اعود اليك
بعد قليل الى الموضوع اساسي وهذا هو هذه
الصور الاولى وهذا هو اول الواصلين الان
هناك فرحه واضح جدا من ان الرايه الصين
الذين وصلوا للان هم سعيدون جدا من خلال
سلامهم الحار واشتياقهم للوصول الى بر
الامان هنا ايضا القنصل الصيني في مدينه
جده ايضا احبهم وهناك ايضا المزيد من
النازلين من الرايه الصين على من هذه
السفينه قاعده اعود الى العمليه التنظيميه
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هي قاعده عسكريه
سعوديه هناك العديد من الفرقات وعديد من
السفن السعوديه الحربيه التي هي فقط
المعنيه بالوقوف على هذا الرصيف لا تبعد
كثيرا عن ميناء جده الاسلامي منها جدا
اسلامي هو منفصل تماما عن هذه القاعده فمن
جد الاسلامي هو اساسا هو فقط للسفن
التجاريه والسفن ايضا المدنيه سواء
التجاريه التي تحمل بضائع او كذلك التي
تقل اعداد المسافرين سواء الذين كانوا في
السابق وما زالوا قادمين ياتون من السودان
او ايضا من مصر او كذلك سفن كروز التي
كانت تصل
تقف على رصيف ايضا ميناء جدا اسلامي هنا
العمليه مختلفه لاننا نتحدث عن ميناء ليس
فقط هو ميناء
عابر وانما هو ميناء تجاري ضخم يعد من
اكبر الموانع الموجوده في العالم وايضا مع
الرؤيه التطويريه للسعوديه فان هذا
الميناء سوف يعزز من خدماته خاصه في
الخدمات اللوجستيه وكذلك في خدمات خدماته
البضائع في عمليات النقل
لدول اوروبا وكذلك عبر اسيا هذا هو امر
منفصل فعندما نتحدث عن هذه السفينه تحديدا
فنحن نتحدث عن وقوفها في ميناء جده
الاسلامي لي على عمليه الاتساع والمساحه
الكبرى التي تتسعها مثل هذه السفينه او
تقف في هذه السفينه نعم
ونحن نتابع هذه الصور المعبره جدا حدثتني
منذ قليل عن سيارات اسعاف تقف للتاكد من
سلامه الواصلين ما الخدمات الاخرى سواء
طبيه او غيرها التي توفرتها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بخصوص هذه العمليات عمليه الاجلاء
طبعا دائما الذين يتم اجلاؤهم الى
السعوديه اولى المراحل التي يقومون بها او
تقوم بها الصحه السعوديه التاكد من
سلامتهم فحصهم التاكد من خلوهم من
الفيروسات هناك تقنيات بوجود كاميرات
حراريه يتم نقل هؤلاء المسافرين الى داخل
الصاله وبعد ذلك يتم كشفهم للتاكد من
خلوهم من هذه الفيروسات وايضا اعطائهم بعض
اللقاحات
الحيويه التي ايضا تعطيهم وتقيهم من هذه
الفيروسات او لا سمح الله من اي مكروبات
قد تصيبهم جراء تنقلهم من منطقه الى منطقه
اخرى اذا هي لقاحات وقائيه من اجل صحتهم
وسلامتهم هناك ايضا مركبات اسعاف ولو
نشاهدها ايضا ونطلع عليها ونرصدها عبر
شاشه العربيه هي تقف ايضا في حاله الطوارئ
بعض بعض الفترات او بعض السفن تطلب
سيارات او مركبات اسعاف من اجل ان هناك
حالات طارئه يتم نقلها او تكون على
السفينه فهناك ايضا مركبات اسعافيه
للطوارئ لحالات الطوارئ في حاله لا سمح
الله حدوث اي ارهاق او اي عمليات للتعب
جراء الرحله الطويله والرحله الشاقه اضافه
الى الرحله الشاقه التي شاهدوها سواء
كانوا في الخرطوم او بورت سودان او ايضا
اثناء سفرهم عبر الماء البحري او المياه
البحريه في السعوديه
قامت بتامين الممر المائي حتى وصول هذه
السفينه الى هذا الرصيف في منها جده
الاسلامي بكل سلام وامان سنعود لك على
فكره هاني الصوره جميله ونحن تابعنا
وجوههم وهمم يعني هناك ارتياح عنده وصولهم
للمياه سنبقى معك وسنبقي الصوره كذلك
لمتابعتها ولكن ستتابع معك لانه هذه
الساعه انتهت هاني الساعه القادمه
ستتابعها معك ليال مع المزيد من التفاصيل
والتطورات فيما يخص هذا الموضوع الصوره
تتحدث وصول رعايه صينيين وكان زميلنا هاني
اصفياني وحدثنا كذلك عن الاجراءات وكيف
تتم هذه العمليه بعد قليل ليال تتابع معكم
هذه التغطيه ونعود لك هاني ابقى معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات